oh you
before
for space
just Skies
forever
ways of Grace
how was it how did it feel it sounded
magnificent well thank you it was uh I
was glad I'm glad I'm done yeah yeah
because it's a
as you're up there you're just hoping
that you get through every note and do
it right
God
America
[Music]
God said it is
I thought this year was special because
both you and Chris basically just went
out there and played it was you your
guitar and the world
yeah that
one or two be on the field with him
because he's so he's so good and it was
a it was a nice contrast for for how I
sing and how he sings and stuff it was I
thought he was well done walked out
there tell me about the hoodie is that
new special this is a uh called Shine
the Light on it's an organization go
sign the light on and they raise money
for mental awareness and and I'm gonna
um I'm helping to sell too and and
donate to Mommy donate money to keep
memory alive which is a organization
that's in Las Vegas that raises money
for
as Alzheimer's and and my mom had
Alzheimer's and so this organization is
really great
it's another thing off your list that
you go check I've done it again what is
that like looking down the list of all
the things you do you take and that this
is the biggest stage
this one I didn't see this coming
um very thankful to Rock Nation to Jay-Z
for even opening the door and saying and
saying yeah him let him do this because
it wasn't anything that I saw coming I
think anybody saw coming for that matter
and uh so I just knew I had to just be
emotional as I can as heartfelt as I
could and be myself and then hopefully
it works that well so
[Music]
do you see
[Applause]
me
[Music]